des données bien sûr de ce rappel au
règlement
l'ordre du jour appelle maintenant la
question orale de mettre Madame
Catherine traîne les à Madame la
Ministre de la réforme de l'État de la
centralisation et de la fonction
publique que nous saluons
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues je souhaite
attirer votre attention sur les
difficultés rencontrées par certains
syndicats mixtes dans le cadre du
renouvellement d'un emploi contractuel
au sein de leur structure la loi du 12
mars 2012 relative à l'accès à l'emploi
titulaire et à l'amélioration des
conditions d'emplois des agents
contractuels dans la fonction publique a
pour but de lutter contre la
reconstitution de l'emploi précaire dans
la fonction publique et d'améliorer les
perspectives professionnelles des agents
contractuels et redéfinis notamment les
conditions de durée et de renouvellement
des contrats afin de prévenir les
situations de renouvellement abusif de
contrat durée déterminée sur des besoins
permanents comme temporaires des
administrations et modifie les
conditions d'accès au CDI toutefois des
questions des cas spécifiques peuvent se
présenter comme pour ce syndicat mixte à
vocation multiple pour le traitement des
déchets ménagers dans mon département
qui a la suite d'une contractualisation
avec l'ADEME en octobre 2010 ils ont
contractualisé un programme local de
prévention des déchets ce syndicat
procédé à l'embauche en CDD de deux
chargées de mission mis à disposition
par le Centre de Gestion du Haut-Rhin ce
mode de recrutement paraissait le plus
pertinent du fait que le financement de
l'ADEME est validé que sur 5 ans
les CDD actuels arrivent donc à terme et
il convient pour le syndicat de les
renouveler
néanmoins à présent les conditions de
recours aux agents contractuels dans le
cadre d'un emploi non permanent doivent
répondre soit un accroissement
temporaire ou saisonnier d'activité
lorsque cette charge ne peut être
assurée par des fonctionnaires soit pour
voir au remplacement d'un agent
indisponible titulaire ou contractuel
pour ce syndicat madame le ministre il
s'agit bien d'un accroissement
temporaire d'activités or les CDD d'un
an pour cause d'accroissement temporaire
d'activités ne peuvent désormais être
renouvelés que tous les 18 mois compte
tenu de la situation économique actuelle
il apparaît nécessaire de procéder à
assouplissement de ses règles
relative au renouvelablement décédé dès
notamment pour les petits structures
pour faire face à cette accroissement
justement de d'activités temporaires
aussi madame le ministre je vous serais
vraiment reconnaissante de bien vouloir
me faire savoir si des mesures peuvent
être mises en oeuvre pour répondre à
cette attente qui est plutôt pressante
merci merci ma chère collègues madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le Président et avec
votre autorisation dire à monsieur le
sénateur que je vais naturellement être
relais de ce qu'il a dit ce matin et que
en tout cas le gouvernement comme je
reprends votre expression entre
guillemets ne se fout pas des sénateurs
nous avons peut-être trop réduit le
nombre de personnels dans nos cabinets
un certain nombre de départ n'ont pas
été remplacés peut-être que c'est une
question qu'il faut qu'on se pose sur le
pôle question parce que j'entends bien
que vous n'êtes pas le seul à émettre
une plainte et pourtant le Premier
ministre régulièrement nous demande de
répondre dans les meilleurs délais 14
mois lorsque j'étais parlementaire je
n'aurais sans doute pas trouvé ça
acceptable non plus et je vais emporter
donc la réponse à la question que vous
aviez posé madame
avec mes excuses de d'avoir d'abord
répondu à votre collègue
c'est exactement le genre de difficulté
que nous trouvons sur l'application d'un
très bon texte de loi que Monsieur
Sauvadet avait présenté avec succès le
12 mars 2012 pour répondre aux besoins
temporaires à un certain nombre de
dispositions ont été prévus et vous
évoquez le fait qu'à la suite de
l'octroi d'une subvention de la dame
pendant 5 ans le syndicat a demandé au
centre de gestion de mettre à sa
disposition des agents non titulaires
recrutés pour répondre à un besoin
temporaire et aujourd'hui bien sûr il se
trouve au terme de la période légale de
renouvellement les conditions dans
lesquelles le recours à un agent de non
titulaire pour occuper un emploi non
permanent dans la fonction publique ont
été modifiés par la loi du 12 mars 2012
et dans ce cadre il est prévu que les
contrats conclus pour répondre à un
besoin temporaire ne peuvent se succéder
plusieurs années de suite vous le savez
sans interruption ce qui serait une
négation du caractère temporaire le
nouveau dispositif prévoit qu'un contrat
pour ce motif peut-être conclu pour une
durée maximale de 12 mois renouvelable
avec un une période maximum de 18 mois
consécutifs et les précédentes
d'exposition prévoyaient que pour
répondre à un besoin exceptionnel un
contrat de 3 ans pouvait être conclu
renouvelable une fois toutefois le fait
qu'elle syndicat mixe bénéficie d'une
subvention de l'aide et me durant 50 ne
peut être on a regardé de près cette
disposition ne peut s'analyser comme un
besoin temporaire ou saisonnier au sens
de la loi permettant le recrutement d'un
agent sur une période non titulaire sur
une période de 5 ans cette qualification
n'aurait pas dû pouvoir être retenue
elle ne peut pas prévaloir aujourd'hui
les dispositions de la loi ni en rien
changé c'est le cas majeur y compris
c'est le cas explicite du temps que vous
avez heurté ou que les élus ne se
suivent ont trouvé en face de
une telle du réinitiale n'est d'ailleurs
pas prévue pour un emploi permanent sur
lequel un agent dont titulaire peut en
application de l'article 3 de la loi
statutaire 84 53 du 26 janvier
1984 peut-être recruté on l'espèce il
faut considérer qu'il s'agit d'un emploi
permanent à créer conduisant au
recrutement d'un fonctionnaire ou d'un
agent dont titulaire si celui d'un si un
emploi de fonctionnaire n'est pas
possible dans le respect des conditions
prévues par la loi et à l'expiration de
la subvention le cas échéant et
n'appartiendra l'autorité territoriale
de décider de la suite qu'elle a étant
donné à cette action et des conséquences
éventuelles de sa décision sur les
emplois concernés je pense que dans le
cas express de figure il faut que le
président du syndicat ou un élu en
charge des personnels ou le Directeur
Général des Services puisse rencontrer
les autorités préfectorales locales
pouvoir comment on peut régler cette
question vous savez qu'on peut supprimer
un emploi de la fonction publique
territoriale lorsqu'une fonction
n'existe plus donc je pense que c'est
comme ça qu'il faut s'or ienter parce
qu'on ne peut pas déroger à la loi sur
un seul cas sinon naturellement c'est
une jurisprudence et la loi de Monsieur
Sauvadet chuterait ainsi de façon
dommageable je vous remercie merci
madame la ministre
souhaitez répondre ma chère collègues
oui merci beaucoup madame la miss de ces
explications il est évident que le
syndicat ne sera pas forcément convaincu
de votre argumentaire même si nous
cherchons effectivement à comprendre
parfaitement ce que vous avez dit il est
vrai qu'on ne pouvons pas mettre à mal
cette législation qui lutte contre
l'emploi précaire mais vous savez aussi
madame la ministre qu'aujourd'hui les
structures notamment ces syndicats de
cette taille là n'auront plus les moyens
financiers de créer de nouveaux emplois
des CDI notamment puisque c'est ce que
vous proposez mais évidemment je
transmettrai votre proposition de ce
rapprochement des services préfectoraux
pour trouver une solution pour continuer
justement cette programmation qui est
très très importante dans le cadre de la
mise en oeuvre des missions de ce
syndicat merci Madame le Ministre merci
madame Tremblay
l'ordre du jour donc maintenant appelle
la question orale de Monsieur Jean